this morning metro police are still
looking for the person who opened fire
inside a hookah lounge one person was
killed 13 others injured madison
kimbrough spoke with the security guard
who works there and he says this could
have been prevented
people started fighting and guns got
pulled out that's that's the
neighborhood that's what happens a
shooting saturday morning at manny's
glow ultra lounge in the central valley
leaves one man dead and 13 people hurt
david a security guard at the hookah
lounge was not there at the time of the
shooting but says he reached out to the
owner with concerns before i'm not
surprised all this happened i've been
trying to talk to the owner about
getting some more real security guards
instead of his friends david says the
lack of qualified security guards made
this place an easy target for something
like this to happen i was the only
dependable security guard there everyone
else
either wasn't a security officer or was
a convicted felon
or they just wanted to play the part
security officer stating that basic
security measures such as pat downs and
using a metal detector wand did not take
place some people who work nearby say
while the shooting is tragic it's
nothing new for the area it comes with
the neighborhood though
obviously this isn't the best part of
the city while others who have been
around for years say otherwise i'm not
so sure it's the area itself
this particular incident is just from
the people it brought in madison
kimbrough live local now
david the security guard who madison
interviewed he believes the victim who
is 33 year old demetrius beard was an
employee of the lounge the lounge owner
had no comment heather